hace dos meses que mi hija se dedica a
cada rato libre a netanyahu
este joven árabe-israelí nunca ha votado
por el likud el partido de derecha del
primer ministro pero esta vez le hace
campaña cómo puedo convencerte de votar
para el likud para convencer a miembros
de su comunidad de que voten por
netanyahu usa los argumentos que le
hicieron cambiar su propia opinión le
digo a la gente que deje de quejarse y
deje de decir no nos dan nada no tenemos
nada les digo que deberían acercarse a
los lugares donde se toman las
decisiones que nos afectan a todos
hay cero árabes en el gobierno unirse a
un gran partido sirve a los intereses de
nuestra comunidad
más allá de nuestra mano
el likud de esta nueva estrategia como
una consecuencia de la reciente
normalización entre israel y los estados
árabes
desde los acuerdos de ahora los acuerdos
de paz con los países árabes veo más
interés en esa comunidad vemos que
tienen un impacto no sólo cambian las
cosas afuera sino adentro de israel
más dividen tira una ciudad árabe en el
norte de israel aunque netanyahu llevó
su campaña hasta allí no es popular y
para más y es difícil convencer a la
gente para ellos el primer ministro no
influye en su problema principal el alza
del crimen como los tiroteos desde
coches
estoy en contra del likud en estas
elecciones porque son la razón por la
cual no podemos resolver el problema del
crimen en la comunidad árabe no pedimos
grandes proyectos ni puertos y que nos
acerquen al mar no pedimos nada solo paz
y seguridad
osella la desconfianza de los israelíes
árabes hacia el likud sigue alta pero un
sondeo reciente muestra que uno de cada
tres votantes árabes quiere que
netanyahu siga siendo primer ministro